lebanon has been plunged into darkness
after its two largest power stations
were shut down due to a prolonged fuel
shortage officials say the outage will
last several days many in the country
rely on private generators but diesel is
in short supply neighboring iran has
pledged to send more fuel shipments
lebanon has suffered several power cuts
in recent months amid an economic crisis
that has seen the value of its currency
fall by 90 percent since 2019. the army
has been deployed to stop bank runs in
beirut
uw correspondent razan salman joins us
now from beirut rezan it's good to see
you power cuts have been an ongoing
issue in the country but now all of
lebanon is without electricity how did
it get to this point
uh well lebanon's electricity shut down
completely after the alvaro and
run out of fuel
the network is very unlikely to work
again before monday or even later which
means that lebanon will plunge today
into total darkness
uh
this this is
uh
corruption there has been corruption in
the power uh a sector for decades now
and uh according to
prevention
the first condition to offer financials
after reforms has been done in this
sector since more than half of the
national debt uh
has been caused to uh cover the expenses
of this sector around 46 billion dollars
in 25 years
now people are facing many difficulties
there we've known about the layers of
the various crises going on we saw there
were protests in recent days outside a
bank in beirut people were desperate to
withdraw money and now a mass power
outage officials saying it's going to
take a couple of days but how are people
coping right now
uh well people's account has been have
been frozen in banks since the october
uprising uh uh people people have been
enduring uh this economy this
unprecedented common economic crisis and
now the total uh plunging into the total
darkness
people have been relying on private
generator uh generators which have been
increasingly expensive uh since they
rely on the black market due to
shortages in fuel and diesel and also
because of
the devaluation of the local currency
against the u.s dollars
so basically whatever the people are
earning they are spending on private
generators
and for example children are forced to
sleep on balconies to avoid the heat and
the people are forced to throw
everything they have stored in their
fridges
because uh
there are power cuts between 18 and 22
hours daily
and some of the lebanese areas
dw correspondent razan salman reporting
from beirut thank you
now the country is struggling with
multiple crises after last year's
massive explosion in the capital beirut
which compounded political and economic
woes many people are suffering including
those serving in the military their
wages are worth less and less amid
rampant inflation now they're finding
unusual ways to increase their earnings
captain hassan through never thought it
would come to this
a highly trained military pilot for more
than a decade he now spends part of his
working day as a tour guide because
we're facing an economical crisis now
in lebanon so the army wanted to
to lessen the impact of this crisis on
the lebanese citizens the army now is
seeking to be a productive army
that means taking tourists on
sightseeing joyrides in normal times
he'd be using this chopper to train the
next generation of pilots but now the
armed forces are trying to make some
cash 150 us dollars gets you 15 minutes
up here to see lebanon from above the
money goes towards maintaining this lead
while it doesn't seem like much it comes
in the much needed fresh currency
from above the country is breathtaking
but on the ground life now is hard
we've hidden this soldier's identity
because he fears reprisals for speaking
up
lebanon's two-year-old economic crisis
has hurt people's incomes and everyday
lives but for many soldiers it's also a
test of loyalty
i
i joined the army because i love my
country and i wanted to secure my future
now i force myself to get out of bed and
arrive at my workplace all depressed
my wife asks me why are you so angry
i tell her life is unbearable
before the crisis george earned the
equivalent of around 800 euros a month
but chronic hyperinflation means he now
takes home less than a tenth of that
so he has to spend all his spare time
moonlighting doing anything that will
pay
for
i'm constantly looking for work
i would collect garbage if i had to just
to survive with my family
now he just wants out of the army but
the policy is no one can leave
some are doing it anyway across town i
meet infantry soldier ali not his real
name who's on the run
i'm still not fully convinced of my
decision
in the beginning i didn't want to leave
[Music]
but it's been two years in this
situation
in this tough situation i don't have the
capacity to survive anymore
in the end i have a family and this is a
responsibility
ali made several official applications
to leave but each time he was rejected
so he says he had no choice and now
fears for his life
i'm sitting at home all anxious at the
sounds of cars
what mistake have i done to deserve
just one of the many men and women in
lebanon who signed up to defend their
country that now feel they're being left
to fend for themselves
you